wouldn't be me otherwise okay I would
ask people how they're doing but like
it's a mess right now and um you don't
need me to tell you that so let's uh
we'll jump into this pretty quickly uh
love the shirt me too
this is a new shirt this was a birthday
present not sent to me by Annie you
folks they got my pile right there
that's waiting for Tuesday's regularly
scheduled livestream but this was
actually given to me by my daughter's
mother who I introduced to Buffy and we
always loved that hole out for a walk
[ __ ] so let's be honest things are
crazy and suck and not worth lingering
on and I kind of got in a bit of a mood
because like the numbers on today's
videos are in today's videos completely
in the toilet and I don't know why other
than I know YouTube cut a bunch of staff
and the automated systems they put in
place don't seem to be cutting it in a
number of different ways so you know
something to lighten the mood and have
some fun I think was in order for
definitely for me and I thought maybe
for some other folks as well oh hey
there Rebecca Carolyn hey pirates
everybody so we're gonna do something
silly you are gonna help me do some
Doctor Who Mad Libs this was a Christmas
present from my daughter so let's see
now you folks are gonna help me fill
this it in and then I shall give you
dramatic readings of the results I've
done that one before
okay so I am going to be asking
you folks for the various words that I
need now if you want to jump you're
suggesting to the top there is the super
chat I'm not gonna require you to do
that by any means I'll look at the
suggestions that I get and and we'll see
how it goes but yeah so try and keep the
the flat out what's the word I want
xsplit explicit and like the swears out
of the suggestions I don't mind racy
I can work with racy but like try and be
more clever than just swear words if you
can we'll see what we get maybe you'll
suggest a swear word that will feel
perfect we'll find out how's your family
doing my family's doing just fine
thankfully I also started working from
home today which is I mean I've done it
before but like this is a different
kettle of fish
anyways so first from you folks I need
an adjective so let's see what you folks
want to come up with obscenities is the
word you can use that too ah-ooh going
with moist um I need a noun oh those are
some good ones hold on to some of those
folks those are good
so we're onto a noun bananas per me oh I
like waffle we're going with a waffle
I'm basically just letting the things
roll by and see what jumps out at my eye
so I'm not even looking who's suggesting
so it's not personal either who I take
or who I skip over so madmen okay well
next one was gonna be a verb so Julie
that that you get that one
so now we need a verb soufflés I'm
enjoying just seeing the the things
ooh tackle gotta go with that one um ooh
oh boy
yeah this will be interesting um I need
an exclamation lik oh dear good gyrate
oh boy some of these things
Ragna okay that's puzzled cheekers oh
wow that's that's a lot um let's go with
hark
I need another adjective oh man uh spicy
smelly freaking cold flaking doll a dead
ooh swanky I'd spotted that one earlier
I need a verb and sophomoric
[Music]
ooh I like spread it's inherently
suggestive at least to me because I do
filthy mind
all right now somebody immediately goes
spread ebook yes I was implying that ooh
you know what we're gonna go with gnome
I need a verb ending in ing Mexico go
velvet aureus moisture moisturizing Wow
I'm just watching this thing fly by I'm
taking porking I need an adjective
[Music]
wait wait I'm using toy I'm taking that
I need another exclamation I'm one of
the you folks are just diving headfirst
into this this is great already
another exclamation gobbledygook wanky
dang it river truth good grief
um joint we're going with you Inc
I need a noun it's a me Mario Chris
Chibnall I feel like I've seen typicals
name come up
Oh Bongo I like Bongo I need a verb
ending an ING and also I don't know like
apologies to Caroline and pirates cuz so
many of the suggestions are getting
flagged and they having to check these
I can't hiding slaying dancing toasting
cranking braiding dreaming pirating yeah
let's do that
uh I need a noun
beginning with the letter S you don't
get those too often one that begins with
a certain thing least I don't remember I
heard I don't do mad libs all that much
scarf scammer skinny um I saw slinky I
like slinky uh we're almost there
three more folks I need a noun uh it
doesn't need an S in the front this time
although it can have one you know what
well go with it it will take saliva I
was very enthusiastic oh dear
okay um one more exclamation
ooh I'm taking fork and finally one last
adjective never repairs lacking handsome
sexy you know what let's go sexy okay
here we go
oops hmm so the mad lib that we have is
it's bigger on the inside so it's sat in
the middle of the field a moist big blue
waffle the doctor says it's his madmen
and he uses it to tackle off into space
hark
it hardly looks swanky enough to spread
one no never mind going porking around
the toy universe yunk i've got a bigger
bungle at home you don't hear me
pirating on about it he calls it his
TARDIS which stands for time and
relative dimension in a call it a saliva
box because that's what it looks like
well and so the TARDIS we go
I still can't see how we'll both work
how's this possible it's more sexy on
the inside than it is on the outside
[Laughter]
[Music]
saliva but yeah I was happy with that
one and yet the toy universe but that
one came out nice I rather enjoyed the
sounds like something 11 would say
feasibly uh-oh
yes the line with Boggs I feel like that
one's sticking in the mind a little bit
email this terminal right now he we need
this as a script for series 13 oh dear
still got nothing on your average cards
against humanity' Ron that's true
but I can't really do that by myself I
need like other people for me to try
I've got the game anyways let's fire up
another one here so let's start off I
need a verb ending in ing huh yes
Carolyn I will work something out
frisking kissing extrapolate you know
what we're going noted we're going
spanking cuz I saw it and yeah my mind
can hang out in the cesspit for a little
bit umm adjectives if you would please
thrusting oh dear mm-hmm
that would have worked too um have you
seen Transamerica I have not it's not a
film I ever felt a particularly desire
to see ooh
girthy I like girthy you know what's
always fun is we you suggest something
intending it to be dirty then it gets
tagged or something that I like it well
that doesn't work so that can be fun as
well um so I need a noun no definitely
not pickle work right Sakura bala boys
you're gonna keep some guessing it
aren't you um heito ballot you go poof
note let's let's go let's go with a nice
sci-fi sounding word the node so I need
a verb ending with I ng
yeah trans madding maybe squandering
nope not that one
Oh
fluffing I like flu fing see it really
is a dice roll as to whether out of the
suggestions I go for the slightly dirty
one they're just silly one it could get
like I I'm all over the place with this
um I need a verb do you think serious 13
will be Jody's last or will she stick
around a bit longer than doctors usually
you I don't know I mean I'm kind of
going in assuming that it'll be your
last one just because of patterns dance
listen seduce splatter like splatter
I need a noun
okay so but nah nah so with the with the
super chat that happen with the exclaim
ice plug that in for the next verb I
will need so that's now covered I need a
plural noun bibley noun is a noun that's
true sheeps sheeps always sounds weird
like as a plural Shih Tzu's you know
what we're taking fangirls okay
nouns oh okay so I'm out of now so
that's getting stuck on the next one so
hold on let me get that down well I
think of it ah ah going to watch a
fourth doctor sir now which one should I
will always recommend city of death like
ever forever okay so hold on backing up
I need oh dear oh boy
uh-huh I need a part of the body what
are you folks gonna do I'm Pierre uvula
say uvula a number of places um
[Music]
spleen spleen it's just a funny word and
finally I need a verb
um Oh canoodle I like a new little
alright this one's gonna be interesting
okay the spanking angels are one of the
most girthy species in the universe the
node light creatures only come to life
when you are not floating at them when
you're out flew f---ing at them if they
do catch you they will send you back in
time where you'll be trapped until you
splatter to protect yourself heed the
doctor's warning
they're coming if they touch you they'll
send you back in banana the weeping
fangirls are coming for you but listen
your life could depend on this
don't exclaim don't even exclaim exclaim
and you're dead they are fast faster
than you can believe
don't turn your spleen don't look away
and don't canoodle good luck
try a mad lib with a theme like Disney
or Star Trek or Star Wars that's not a
bad suggestion Rebecca I've only got the
Doctor Who mad lib book though uh the
weeping fangirls yeah that that worked
out quite well
no one should canoodle these days Oh
true story uh boy so don't canoodle with
spanking angels or weeping fangirls
words to live by
I meant use words that associate with
Disney or others should and should as a
cross over oh well the see if one comes
up in the suggestions that I like you
have a tongue a Tom Hanks lab that's new
usually people comment on my laughs it's
accused of being unsettling or Joker s
so that's that's a new one like I can't
remember I can't remember you'd like
hearing some thanks laughing now it's
not my head I feel like dig something up
are you quarantined no I am however
socially distanced I am working from
home my kids out of school yeah so
anyways
next up not sure how many we'll end up
doing but we're definitely doing at
least one more because I'm having a good
time hope you folks are to the let's see
I need an adverb
as someone who's erased Catholic the
phrase spanking angels tour girthy he
brings up complicated feelings for me
ooh sorry Ben sorry if I just I just
made that tricky for you
how old is your kids or is he kids
rather this much no it's just the one
I've medically ensured that it will only
be the one who's seductively I do like
that my child is eight pedantically
that's interesting you kept repeating
right okay so I need I need a plural
noun and I was a unicorn owned not a
eunuch they don't uh who showgirls um
they don't remove that much when you get
a vasectomy so let's see uh adjectives
please
squishing magical gassy pedantic sly
stitches one cinco slow 'ln let's go
with that I need a place
clumb no no we're good we're gone with
clone clones gone home all right I'm
getting adjective I'd like Captain
Caveman worked in there somewhere
ooh hold that thought
so right now with adjectives I'm waiting
on tangled greasy Harry goes st and a
color
blood-red moe let's move ah room line
must be brown lavender oh you should
kidney color but kidney color what it
what if you don't like the color of your
kidneys um okay uh I gotta go I gotta go
with one of these um mo we're doing mo
does the one that's stuck in my head
alright I need
oh boy uh part of the body please folks
brain toenail it's help pipe humorous
handicapped bellybutton Wow um I'm
something to her eyebrow tumor my coccyx
we're going coccyx I'll probably spelled
it wrong but I'll know what it is a
plural noun how are there are over a
hundred people I'm here watching me
drink water and do mad libs elbows noses
nerds fanboys follicles Daleks Batman
fish finger Oh fish fingers yeah fish
fingers
another part of the body Bendis
all right fine weenus will do weenus
good grief
people been dropping that one for a
couple goes now all right I need a verb
ending an ING being over exaggerated and
dramatic uh-oh ooh tugging I think I
like tugging no I like sucking oh and
super chat for tibia so got that in
there at a point where it's going to
work so I need a noun thank God um oh
there's one I want to use what I'm not
going to oh man Wow um you know what
we're gonna go hmm Oh God um how god
I've like that I like keep I keep seeing
like ones that I want to remember and
then they zoom past and then I've lost
it huh this is going well um whiskey
just whiskey take that
I need another noun hopefully I can
focus better this time
I don't think I'm gonna use chicken
nuggets
it's not calling to me I can see
someone's trying to tag me but like I'm
not it's zooming past I'm not gonna see
it
who Spaceballs and I need an exclamation
you people are dirty I like it I'm not
gonna use a lot of them but I like it
dad's Zonk babushka Benny we're going
with that um just so I need an adjective
and then we're good to go
swimmingly rosy sixteen juicy crispy
cheesy abundant ah let's do frisky okay
all right so my friends you are about to
have an unexpected adventure I'm so
professional in all right
the cloister Bell sounds as the doctors
seductively pulls on nouns and presses
the multicolored showgirls on the
control panel yeah I just got a mental
image Oh God
oh great another swollen landing you
brace yourself
hoping this destination will be better
than the last trip to klom suddenly the
door swings open to reveal a zesty move
sky and the delightful smell of Captain
Caveman
come on the doctor calls as he grabs
your coccyx and pulls you into this new
world let me around you spot majestic
fish fingers as far as the weenus can
see suddenly sucking in your direction
is what looks like an alien whiskey
creature the doctor pulls out his sonic
space balls and shouts bed the creature
stops and extends its tibia the doctor
reaches out and shakes the aliens tibia
oh no this could get frisky I'm not I
wasn't planning to run this for her for
the usual hour that I do this oh I think
I think I'm only gonna do one more
because that I did add stuff I want to
get done tonight but this
I I don't know about you folks but I am
getting exactly what I wanted out of
this which is just a lightning
experience and I'm definitely getting
that I just arrived and already things
are becoming not-safe-for-work
well more so in the chat van then from
my end Connor
although like it's it's good oh oh you
gotta give me $100 to read another
culture book cool awesome I am game for
that I did enjoy the first one I know I
had my nipples but I did enjoy it so I'd
be up for another one huh
is it bad that my mind wanted it to be
11 after seductively I think I have a
crush mm-hmm nothing wrong with that
crush on any and all doctors you feel
like crushing on
can you read bad Doctor Who fan fiction
um I'd have to vet it first so there's a
little more work involved in that I know
like in theory be funnier if I didn't
vet it but that just runs the risk of it
just being boring and dumb and not
actually funny so I would have I would
have to like dig around and find
something um like look I'm not gonna
make any promises but it's a distinct
possibility that I may do more probably
during the week livestreams to unwind at
the end of the day Wow all this stuff is
going on no promises
but I'm saying this sort of impromptu
thing is probably a little bit more
likely so if anybody wants to hit me up
council of geeks at gmail.com with
suggestions for bad fanfic I will
consider doing a fanfic reading okay so
we're gonna do one more and one more and
then I do have to knuckle down and then
like be productive and stuff
ah okay so I need a verb ending in I and
G what if I write a bad a fanfiction
give it a shot the movie
ooh I like yodeling I need is David
Bradley better as Hartnell uh or one um
I mean David Bradley is just doing
Hartnell so I don't I don't feel like
you can you can detach those and handle
them differently anyway so it says I
need a person in the room female however
you folks we're going to interpret that
we paint
oh you know what you know what it's a
cheap joke but it's the last one we're
gonna do I'm going with your mom I need
an adjective baby's mom oh dear
dirty flirtatious mr. cheesy moldy angry
the silliest hot bum chunky hairy hangry
sparkly ah ooh kinky yeah sure
oh boy this is gonna be interesting um I
need a number I have a hunch woods
what's gonna jump out there it is I mean
a lot more numbers than I expected a lot
of 42 okay now we're going 69 let's be
dumb and let's be 14 this round sure why
not
I need a verb in the past tense my
social security number uh demoted
crunched doctored erected um yeah we'll
do that I need a noun
1914 my 13 isn't my birthday is in 11
days ooh toilet roll that's on people's
minds I need an adjective
Eurovision house-elf
weeping fangirl oh man legitimately
Karen I'm so sorry I did not realize
what a nightmare it was gonna be to try
and Maude for holy crap um wanky sticky
spicy fuzzy wobbly mmm
wanky
all right I need a color
who chartreuse which I won't spell
correctly but roll with it and I need an
article of clothing panties so that
coming
socks scarf speedo ooh
you know we'll go dirty but the classy
way to say it let's do knickers all
right I need a verb ending in ing your
brain
interesting choice for article of
clothing printing dying devouring
swatting planking scrumping I don't even
know what that is but I'm using it I
need an adverb winding down one two
three five to go uh badly swimmingly
hastily ooh desperately that's now
actually that one's gonna end up being
too too normal
so that's lustfully sure let's just
let's just go that way um I need a noun
lizard Benny Benny got his limelight Fez
juice sprocket a surround um I like
Twinkie
um and I need a verb our people walk
back through
rust I'm taking thrusts I need an adverb
someone slyly March only stupidly
unnecessarily then Benny Angley merrily
fiscally moodily joylessly oh that hurts
slowly subtly hypocritically slinky
Chris yeah Frisco Lee will know that and
I need a place for Scalini so let's see
Calgary hello Canada Mars New Jersey and
not the same as hell
Oh
alright I'm not gonna tell you what I'm
going with but I'm just going with it
alright here we go
mmm there's gonna be a last one and then
I do have to do stuff so here we go
where or should we go today the familiar
sound of the TARDIS yodeling nearby woke
your mom from a kinky sleep after
waiting for nearly sixty nine minutes
the doctor finally came back for her she
quickly jumped out of bed and directed
out into the morning air in the distance
she saw the familiar blue toilet roll
and the lanky man wearing his trademark
chartreuse knickers come along he called
out we need to get scrumping she
lustfully kept running straight into the
TARDIS the doctor smiled as he pressed a
button on the TARDIS Twinkie and asked
what do you think where should we thrust
today sheaf riskily replied your mom
don't follow the wiki man asking to
scrub yeah like I I feel like that's uh
that that's a mistake
broadly speaking yeah one more no I
can't
I'm like I do generally have stuff that
I need to do and that includes finish
this will you do a ranking of the
doctors outfits
um I mean maybe I might throw it up as
an option for when I start doing
lists again I mean I'm sure I'll get to
it eventually
can we super chat by all means I am kind
of wrapping up but I won't say no this
is the bad place yeah yeah GP might well
be opinion on seven keys to doomsday I
haven't
seen that one yet it's one of the ones I
haven't gotten to scrumping is stealing
apples off a tree I actually knew that
well I like I say that I'd forgotten
that but like I knew I'd heard that word
before then you said I'm like that I did
actually know that at some point the
doctors will hum and I picture Amy oh no
what is your least favorite costume
other than the sixth doctor's uh-huh I
didn't like the last one that they had
for in where they first put like the
question marks on his on his collar that
that wasn't his look Seven Keys is
actually an audio of a stage play oh oh
okay
no um I was confusing it with there's a
there's a there's a fifth doctor
something something to doomsday so
that's what I confused it with so no no
I definitely haven't encountered that
yet to buy some toilet roll much
appreciate it I can find some that's it
that's its own worry forward to doomsday
thank you scrumping is one of the crimes
Lister said he didn't read dwarf in the
episode Oh justice huh whence scrumping
four cars oh that's right
have you read the Kingsmen and kick-ass
comics I have not I'm I'm not a huge fan
of Mark Millar's writing like I like
some of his ideas I don't like is
writing though I just kind of don't
don't forget I'm only 13 yeah thanks for
reminding me Andrew now I like I feel
guilty that I'm here with a wine and let
the chat get dirty great thanks
did you know they asked Louise Louise
Jamison back is Lila for Baker's last
episode Davidson's first full season I
did not
Disney Plus launches here on Tuesday
great timing well I mean that'll give me
something to do for a little bit all
right I'm gonna answer one last question
then we're gonna bow out if you could
have Whitaker being a story with one
other doctor whom um
I'd like to put her with seven I think
they're gonna end they would end up
having a lot more in common than I would
have thought after her first series so
anyways thanks for stopping in folks
this was this was fun and this did for
me exactly what I wanted this just kind
of brightened me up a bit so much
appreciated everybody just you know all
the things you need to do as much as
that as much as it sucks the social
distancing is necessary wash your hands
stay healthy take care of yourself take
care of your loved ones and by doing
this we take care of the most vulnerable
among us so I will do what I can to ease
the days in my own way but you know just
just stay safe Kovu 19 shows the
importance of telephone sanitizers in
society this is what took out the goal
of the French uns it's true so good
night everybody and just remember you
are beautiful you're loved and you are
valid
you are the council I just run these
meetings or sometimes these mad libs so
have a good night